[Music]
and don't fall for it news don't do it
nobody never have don't do it emitted by
I love you TIFF yeah
locals reveal which popular souvenirs
Taurus by that they think are pointless
I ever would do ever buy souvenirs some
time for a friend family like Eiffel
Towers or whatever keychains with your
name on them they never have they never
have my name either my no no they don't
they have your name they have your name
they have your no my name is very rare
posted a question on Quora yeah and so
they were saying what do tourists buy in
your country that makes you wonder why
and here are some examples I bet you in
Thailand they go how come they buy the
hookers that's not a souvenir it is if
you bring a CD back yeah that's a that's
a surprise yeah well the souvenir that
last forever I liked in Australia they
were selling kangaroo balls that was
actual balls kangaroo ball sacks and
then they have different things so that
one could be a like a lighter one could
be a family one could be a coin purse I
don't remember the set of actual
kangaroo ball is it I think it is yes
like a lucky rabbit's foot like that oh
people would definitely buy them okay
but they have like kangaroo farmers I'm
not farms but I know they have abundance
of kangaroos yeah certain restaurants do
serve kangaroo yeah why yep yeah yeah I
saw I went to go eat them Andrew Zimmern
details delicious
yeah well kangaroos are also very scary
looking die weird saying that they
they're I mean they're [ __ ] claws all
of them are scary I don't know what
children show I saw that made me think
that kangaroos were nice I guess Winnie
the Pooh but like that's the image of
kangaroos I have then you see a picture
of them and you're like what the [ __ ] is
that
nothing thank you they look like they
were supposed to be humans but God was
like yeah that's what they look human
burn a pocket yep boom and there you go
my god thought they were two legged dogs
beetles like puppies no they look like
God was
one night and he was just like a
platypus looks like a dog and a human
combined that's a platypus bro that's a
lot of [ __ ] are one of those things
that God was having a little too much
fun yeah
God [ __ ] up with Australia no Leah got
a ton of marsupial no he does we love
you coming out so many marsupials in one
area we love you aren't koalas
carnivores no weight that doesn't mean
we're koala is freakiest but a wet koala
yeah you need a Google app I'm good
koalas are really busy get ready because
your minds gonna be lucky am I about to
see a wet cause your life is about to
change for the very cute no that's worse
it's like gremlins you know when they
get them wet crazy look this she's gonna
we're gonna reveal you should we wait if
you haven't seen it stay tuned cause I'm
gonna eat my popcorn somebody's work oh
I don't like that at all I don't like
that at all that's not Wow that's not
water it's not water in closes skin
melted skin is scary as [ __ ]
oh no that [ __ ] looks like an evil owl
you know what's funny when fluffy dogs
get wet they look so stupid as [ __ ] they
like they look so dumb dude like they
thought they were all dope it makes me
feel dope when fluffy dogs get wet cause
it's like a rich person that just got
like [ __ ] dumped on them yeah especially
if they're a skinny dog that's really
fun yeah it's like no your [ __ ] place
you're not that cute mmm-hmm all right
so for the first tourist silver near
pointless thing that people think that
is pointless is in dirt from Germany the
cuckoo clocks the Shirin we're about to
I think they're dope because they're
hand me well the play that tells you
time well the place that we went to they
specialized in in it and then they've
been doing this sense like for centuries
and there was like hundreds of dull boy
lives because it's produced in China oh
the place that we went to they
handcrafted oh yeah yeah we're Americans
we're dumb mm-hmm
whether you wherever you go all over the
world their gift shops it's all made in
China yeah most of these people were
saying that yeah like whenever they were
people don't know that's true so
so the next one is from India the pair
of elephant print pajama pants
that's not sick a lot of tourists buy
them and they're just what's it what's
the elephant represent again
the locals are saying that people from
India or Asian countries in general
never wear these but they always sell
them at the souvenir shops well you say
that's I've seen those kind of pants
though yeah it's like usually you know
the girl that has dreadlocks and smokes
weed or the yogi and the girl that's
like just super show it was really funny
to be people I know that has visited
India that said it was a [ __ ] amazing
spiritual experience was was a white
person no other Asian or Indian person
that I know that has lived there or went
there has never said that that's what
I've heard - probably because they like
plotted out all the tourist spots maybe
or some [ __ ] there like it was so it was
so good and all my life friends who have
Indian parents they're like I would
never go back there ever again there's a
very good reason I have come here I'm
not going back the next item that locals
they are pointless is from Hawaii which
is the grass skirt and coconut true
Hawaiian never wore coconut bras never
walk they let the titties go yeah they
did wear a grass skirt but not the
coconut bras
that's a 1940's invention or something
there's because you know the bare
boobies is like taboo for the white
people's stick them in coconut they try
to figure out when they've had the hula
shows and all that stuff they try to
figure out the next one is from Canada
maple syrup you telling me that shit's
about Canadian it is Canadian but
torrent or locals are saying like men
tourists drink this [ __ ] like it's water
and it's just regular old syrup but
maybe it tastes better because it was
made they check this out
cane Andy Dean's we have something
called high fructose corn syrup and all
our [ __ ] all of our [ __ ] anything
sweet is made out of that corn [ __ ]
so we'll serve oh yeah we have fake
maple syrup it's not even a real maple
syrup
we have to get our maple syrup right it
has to be the organic da da da da and
that shit's like [ __ ] hell expensive
but yours is right there so it's cheaper
so that's why we [ __ ] drink your [ __ ]
yeah like they have their regular maple
syrup is maple syrup our regular is Aunt
Jemima
[ __ ] brown colored sugar high
fructose corn syrup we've had Canadians
give us maple syrup so also this bottle
is sick that looks like some damn
whiskey I buy that and put it on a mat
like on a mantle yeah nice yeah I
actually bought some limoncello when we
went to Italy and shaped into like a
bootleg limoncello it's uh Sorrento's
like signature liqueur or something cuz
they're all about lemons yeah it was
pretty low the name of a Kia SUV
Sorrento damn you know all the weird
[ __ ] corners
why can't you just let me light my
wack-ass cars huh I do I just I'm not
gonna write in it oh yes you will [ __ ]
have I yet you wailed all [ __ ] cuz
Bart's gonna slash your tires and I've
had to pick you up
nope I'm gonna over that I don't think
still good bucks it'll break your phone
you don't have to knock you out
surrounding this car probably just gonna
be so [ __ ] up look I got you and I'm
like literally driving up to you you're
like no I'm good she's got like oh I'm
shot [ __ ] somebody take me to the
hospital David's like I'm here I got too
much game go to the hospital in style oh
my god the dweeb Oh bill is here yeah no
no no oh yeah you're gonna ride in that
car one day we'll see oh yes you will
yes you will my Honda Element never is
from Spain and it's sangria so locals
are saying that buying bottled sangria
to take home is pointless because it
tastes disgusting and it's just easier
and more flavorful for you to make it
that's really easy you can expire but
you know like that I don't know I'm just
saying like all of the non-american
things like the white thing we were like
oh that's stupid but everything else we
were like no that's a souvenir that
literally
all the [ __ ] that they're saying that's
about what is why it sells and you know
what it's giving you money in your
country so don't even judge I would
[ __ ] embrace that [ __ ]
what is our equivalent in California of
a stupid souvenir that pennies do they
buy it Hollywood yeah oh yeah any of
those kiosks sure the Hollywood [ __ ]
that's a lot for Hollywood actually that
says Los Angeles and then like inside
each letter it's like different those
shirts are kind of cool I would like
like Los Angeles and then like in the
letters there's like monuments and
landmarks yeah yeah yeah I've seen that
I've heard New York mugs yeah in the
middle of it I was like that's actually
kind of cool I want to get one of those
well like you know how they say like LA
and it's like sunset with like a palm
like tree or whatever that's actually
kind of cool too well like those
postcards where it's like 1980s and
there's like all these girls with
bikinis and they got flat butts and in
the frizzy hair and stuff it's like a
lineup that's kind of cool too though
you know it's kind of retro [ __ ] and you
know because of the internet too you
could literally get all the [ __ ] for
yourself yeah so like you know when we
go to whole life thing just like every
time I go traveling tonight because my
thing is to get magnets from every place
that I go that's a little different
though you know I mean I'm talking about
let's say like we go to Hawaii right and
then we bring people the macadamia nut
chocolates like thank you but it's also
at the store next to my house people
love that [ __ ] but they also have
flavors that we don't have oh yeah see
that's a little bit I think that's a
good souvenir you could buy something
there that you can't really get it the
food Akaka a popcorn [ __ ] you know I
mean the flavor kick heads from Japan
yeah like Japanese snacks are like the
best I know dude those little like
chicken biscuit biscuit crackers yeah
yeah I don't know what the [ __ ] those
are I had them one time it's like a
little cracker in a circle but it's
chicken but it looks like a biscuit what
damn I just heard you speak with a bad
Joe in the background that [ __ ] was
tight
real [ __ ] with like all the wheat
sticking out her mouth no it's funny mm
Oh somebody she's like she's like how
Korean half white but she grew up in
Kentucky
hmm but she has hid her accents so well
I never knew until I got her drunk it
all when you get drunk it comes out
because we're constantly trying not to
use our exit because like it makes you
look kind of silly I don't know some
people think sometimes it feels that way
yeah turn it on and off though yeah it
kind of control even the accent it gets
like yeah if I get like you don't sound
like what anymore though I know that's
the thing I can't every time I saw you I
was gonna hit up where you from
[Laughter]
[Music]
you